>>Interviewer: Hi everybody.
We are joined today by Chef Marcus Samuelsson;
he is the chef and owner of Red Rooster in
Harlem in
New York City, the winner of Top Chef Masters,
and the author of "Yes, Chef," a memoir chronicling
his extraordinary journey from
Ethiopia to Sweden to Harlem, with many stops
along the way including the White House.
There is a line from "Yes, Chef"--
>>Marcus: And the Google office.
>>Interviewer: And the Google office most
importantly.
>>Marcus: Yes.
>>Interviewer: On 14th Street.
There's a line in "Yes, Chef" that struck
me that I wanted to read: "Who’s going to
make the
people realize that food dismissed as ‘ethnic’
by the fine-dining world could be produced
at the same level as their sacred
bouillabaisses and veloutés?” and I have
to say, after reading "Yes, Chef" the answer
is Chef Marcus Samuelsson.
So please me in
welcoming to Google New York, Marcus Samuelsson.
[Applause]
>>Marcus: Thank you.
>>Interviewer: Glad you're here.
I'm happy to be back.
I've been here twice, one time for the launch
of the African book, "The Soul of a New
Cuisine," and one time with Martha Stewart
for a Christmas thing you guys were doing.
>>Interviewer: And this is the best time--third
time's the best, right?
>>Marcus: It is, by far.
By far.
[Laughter]
>>Interviewer: So I have to admit I read your
book and reading it made me feel like possibly
the laziest human being on the planet
because you have done everything and worked
so hard throughout your career--your quite
long career at this point because you
started quite young.
And I can't even imagine--you're only forty-one
now--which is very young by my standards because
I'm not quite
forty yet--but I can't even imagine what you're
going to do in the next ten or twenty years--so
what made this moment the right
moment to write a memoir?
>>Marcus: I think that there's an evolution
right, as a self and as a chef and I always
actually envisioned to be a good chef by
forty-two or something like that because I
think that's a perfect age in terms of you
know who you are and being a chef, so
much about it is knowing who you are, and
you can express that through food.
But also where I was in my life, you know,
married; I
knew about my Ethiopian side; I also knew
where in the DNA, in terms of my restaurant,
where do I need to be?
Where was it important
for me to be, beside just having a store?
And all of that takes time; it takes time
to become a good chef, not that many become
good chefs, you have to find the conscious
of finding yourself; and then, where do you
need to operate from?
You know, I became
chef very early--maybe too early--but then
also hadn't asked myself those questions of
"Is there something larger?
Can I be part of
changing the footprint in this city?
What's going on in the food chasm in this
specific city, in this country?
What are my
responsibilities?"
>>Interviewer: That's great.
Well, you know, the book is so beautifully
written and, just starting with the first
chapter I have
to admit it actually almost brought me to
tears reading about--the story about your
mother and how you've never seen a picture
of
your birth mother and that vignette was really
a very powerful story--
>>Marcus: Yeah.
>>Interviewer:--And one that I think a lot
of people didn't know about you, if they know
some parts of your life.
Was--when you
read the final manuscript--was there a story
or an event that struck you as particularly
poignant and important to write about?
>>Marcus: Well, I think I want to keep a book
that has the pace of myself.
I mean the chapters are pretty short, so there's
a fast
good pace, it's a quick read.
If you're an immigrant like me, it might take
two weeks, but someone like you who's been
here longer
maybe two days.
[claps hands together] It's a quick, I wanted
to keep a quick read, and also have people
from all walks of life
share it at a dinner table.
If you were seventeen and wanted to--was into
cooking--you could read this book and relate
to it.
If you were the parent, you could sort of
like see yourself in your journey and your
struggles; and if you were the grandparent,
there was this sort of "Oh, that's what we
do with our kids.
We inspire them to cook."
So keeping the pace but also keeping it an
entry level to all people.
You know for me it's important to explain
the journey in terms of profession, specifically,
cheffing is
so different today than it was when I came
in, right?
It was one way, you worked in a French restaurant,
and you worked yourself,
you know, as hard as possible, and the only
way to respond was "yes, chef."
But, just as much as your business evolved,
ours too.
So now people might know cooking through Top
Chef or through an online recipe.
What happened?
What was the difference?
I wanted to
explain that sort of--that journey and also
explain for people from all colors a window
in to how a black laborer's journey is,
because it is different.
Just like a woman's journey is different.
And guys can always say like, "No no it doesn't
matter, there's no
difference.
We're all open."
It is different.
And it's not about an [author] conversation
about race that wasn't polarizing.
It's
like "You know what, I've never thought about
that" and from all sides of it say like "You
know what, that's uh, hmm.
I've never thought about that journey."
>>Interviewer: Let's talk a little bit about
that because you do talk a lot about race
in the book and it's a really fascinating
perspective being one of--really the only--executive
chefs of color in the city, I mean maybe {Chef
Cardo Stenza} there's maybe a handful
in sort of the fine dining arena--
>>Marcus: Mmm
>>Interviewer: But you've really made a mark
for yourself and you write a lot about the
racism that you've faced along the way in
your career,
some of the really off color remarks that
were made to you by quite prominent chefs
that were really disturbing to me and made
me
not want to watch certain programs ever again,
it just--there've been a lot of challenges
that you've faced and what about those
experiences sort of influenced the way you
run your business now?
>>Marcus: I think that I've been lucky enough
to work in really great restaurants and that
taught me what to do, but also taught me
what not to do more than anything.
If I walked into any great French restaurant
that I worked in, there was no women, zero.
It
was--the narrative of the black chef didn't
exist to the point where you had to explain
for them that you were there working in the
kitchen many, many, many times and even when
I got the job, they didn't have the job because
it was a black chef, so that does two
things--that either makes you sharper or quit.
And a lot of people quit and that's their
life answer why you don't have
more diverse entry level in the work force.
And cooking is just one thing, you can say
the same in the tech world, you can say the
same in--I mean, the book is a mirror up--
to look introvert yourself-- to look into
yourself, "You know what?
How does that reflect
MY environment?"
You know?
And I mean the fact that there's not enough
women in the cooking world is just nonsense
because the
most influential people in cooking have always
been women.
>>Interviewer: Sure.
>>Marcus: You can look at it from just eating
around the world, but you can also look at
it from in this country who changed the
game?
Alice Waters and Julia Childs.
We wouldn't have Food TV without Julia.
We wouldn't think--we have fifty-four farmer's
markets in
New York City.
Without Alice asking those questions, maybe
we'd have two.
On the larger scale, who are the biggest game
changers?
Women.
And just that cooking in terms of a restaurant,
in terms of fine dining, which is one segment
of this conversation, could be
argued that it's more suitable for a guy.
It's almost like an Olympic--you run really
really fast but that does not explain what,
who contribute our community and changes how
we eat.
Fine dining cooking is the minority in this
pyramid that we call food--food
community.
>>Interviewer: Well talking about your journey
some more you've had--excuse me, I think I
alluded to this in the introduction--many
many along
this journey and I would love to hear more
about that journey including your time almost
becoming a professional soccer player to
cooking for the White House and some of the
key moments that stand out for you.
If you can just tell us a little bit about
them.
>>Marcus: Well for me one of the key moments
ever was when I was allowed to work for free
for a year.
When I got the chance to work in France.
>>Interviewer: We would hire you for that
for a year, if you wanted to work for free
here.
[laughter]
Just kind of ignoring me--we would pay--
>>Marcus: Well, you know--it would be a good
education for both, I'll tell you that.
We'd be closing the gap on the food chasm,
I'll
tell you that.
I would ask a lot of questions and you guys
are smarter than me so you would fix it.
>>Interviewer: We'd just Google it.
[laughter] And find the answer.
>>Marcus: Yeah, exactly.
No but that chance to work in the three star
Michelin Restaurant in France was for me a
big success because
I sent out thirty-five letters.
Me and my mother went to the local library
to send out a lot of letters and we got just
like a--I
think that the undertone in the book should
be about rejection--how do you deal with rejection?
All of us here have been rejected
and how do you deal with that?
It's in the personal life, it is--it happens
in work place and what you do with that?
And for me it
was actually the perfect time.
You know, I started writing to three star
Michelin Restaurants when I was eighteen-nineteen-twenty
but I didn't get there until I was twenty-three.
But it actually turned out to be better for
me because I was a better cook.
Although each one of those answers back were
painful.
But in the meantime I taught myself French
and I was a better cook.
So the
rejection does not always have to be that
you have to get off your journey, you know,
I went to Switzerland instead of France, and
they spoke French in Switzerland and German
so now I got yelled at in Swedish, German
and French, which was a good advantage
because before I went to France, I need to
know some of that.
So it's being committed to the craft, being
completely in love with
your craft.
If there was anyway I doubted that, there
was no way I would have taken that abuse,
or those things.
I'm also now
thinking about is there a way to create incredible
food without abuse?
>>Interviewer: What's the answer?
>>Marcus: Well, we're searching.
[laughter] Because there is a commitment inside
that you can't doubt that has to happen and
I
think, you know, I think Red Rooster's asked
me a lot of questions and I have to answer
them.
I always trust my work and I seek new
questions in my work.
And you know, I've been lucky enough on the
book tour to travel to some of the best restaurants
in the ci--in
the country and I ask--you know I get a window
in to what's going on in American food and
it's a better plate today.
It's more
diverse whether you eat in Chinese, Muslim
restaurant in San Francisco or you eat at
a good TexMex restaurant in Austin, or you
eat
in a really cool, great fun environment in
Miami, or you eat in Copa in Boston--the kitchens
are more diverse they are--the evolution
is completely different now--I'm so happy
that that's happening.
And I think America is one of the few places
that can create that.
Because the entry
levels to work in a kitchen is still pretty
low but you're curiosity level is very high
so people come from all walks of life which
is great.
I worked in the tech world but now I want
to become a chef.
Look at what Nate's doing in Seattle.
Look at what modern
cuisine is happening there.
That will answer a lot of questions--not just
on the modern American cuisine today--but
those guys are
so bright so they'll probably figure out--maybe
how, maybe they have the question to end famine?
You know because that's how that
modern cuisine is part of what they're working
on and they're also working on these other
things and that's so great where cooks
are coming into this industry not just on
the --the way I got in--that's one way--but
it's so great to have people like Nate and
other people in the conversation because they're
going to ask themselves questions: "How can
we figure out better against diabetes?
Allergies?" and these big questions that we
have that I've find it is important as a chef--we
have to.
Filling restaurants, that's
part of our job and we should be doing this
especially if you have a big platform, you
should be doing that.
>>Interviewer: But driving the larger conversation
about food and how things--
>>Marcus: The larger conversation, absolutely.
And that's what we do, I --my company--I'm
committed to that and that is why we have
community arm that is very strong and we do
cooking classes for free in the community.
That's why we have a tech side that is very
strong.
>>Interviewer: Tell us about the tech side.
What are you doing?
>>Marcus: Well I just felt with MS.com and
FoodRepublic.com--I wanted--what I saw online
didn't sort of match with--the food
conversation I saw online didn't necessarily
match with how-why I got into the industry.
I got into the industry about curiosity
and I went to learn.
So I thought what an opportunity.
What if Food Republic was focused on making
a food platform that was geared
towards men--so it's about forty-five/fifty
five percent men/women--that is women friendly
but that you learned something and we
celebrate each other as chefs so that was
a space that was open so we built a platform
around it.
On MS.com its about
seventy-thirty women to men and there we might
focus on--it's very community oriented to
Harlem--its sort of a map into Harlem but
also what food healthy after yoga or after
you've been working out.
So this adding something to the web space
was about learning and
feeding people's curiosity and become better
cooks and become smarter shoppers in today's
food space.
>>Interviewer: Yeah.
Well it's interesting that you're using the
platform that you've been given or that you've
really created for
yourself between things like Top Chef and
your James Beard Awards and all the rest of
it to really become an activist in the food
movement and maybe people don't know that
much about that, so it's interesting that
you're--I mean it's great that you're doing
that.
>>Marcus: I mean you have to I mean like these
wonderful platforms that you guys are part
of creating--evolving are there for us
as consumers right, so when I opened Red Rooster
and I had doubts I went to Twitter right away
and I was like "Should I have
vintage plates or new plates?" and right away-shoosh-
vintage comes in right?
"Should I do my Jamaican oxtail or Grandma's
oxtail?"
--whoosh--right away.
[interviewer laughs] It's a fun way of engaging
and allowing people all over the world to
participate and
feeling close to this narrative--this conversation.
It's not about self-promotion, that's getting
tired, so I use Twitter as a--I
curate carefully about the food conversation
I want to have and what I see because I'm
lucky to be in Austin one day and Harlem the
next week and then maybe at a food market
somewhere else right?
But I know that the people there hang out
with me online, they want
to be part of that, so I think have to curate--I
can't just post anything, you know?
>>Interviewer: Observation--
>>Marcus: Observation, sifting and making
a yummy, sticky space for the people that
want to engage.
>>Interviewer: It's interesting how you've
used social media to influence the evolution
of Red Rooster.
I think that's very
unusual, because I think chefs come in and
they have such a clear idea of what they want
to do and the personalities of the chefs
that I have met tend to be very controlling
for the most part, not in a bad way, so it's
amazing that you've been able to engage in
that dialog and actually have it influence
your menu and influence the choices that you're
making in a really--
>>Marcus: For me it was Red Rooster and I
didn't grow up in Harlem so I can't say that
I grew up there, but I wanted to create a
restaurant that was a mirror image food wise
of that community.
And some people, depending on where you live,
where you grew up,
know more or less about that community, it's
mystique, it's an old neighborhood, but maybe
everyone doesn't know about what it
really is and I thought, "Well, I've lived
there for ten years, I want to map that out
on a menu.
I want you to taste Harlem."
Well there's obviously a center of African-American
heritage there that we should honor.
There's also el barrio and on top of el
barrio there's a new Mexican community, therefore
the tacquitos.
There's also the Italian corridor, like it's
been there forever,
and then you have this new West African because--yes,
there are Black African Americans, but the
West Africans has another new
ingredient that we might not know about so
that's why we have shrimp powder on the restaurant,
on the menu.
So when you read the
menu of Red Rooster, it's curated and crafted
based on seasonality, but also based on Harlem.
You see Harlem and that's our job
there.
>>Interviewer: That's amazing.
In the--getting back to the book quickly,
you were pretty much an open book through
out the process
and really went raw and told a lot of details,
very personal, deeply personal things.
I think if you're going to right a book like
that obviously you need to be prepared to
do that.
Was there anything you wish you had left out,
or a story that you actually wish
you had included?
>>Marcus: I mean, the process of writing this
book was over five years, three days a week,
I just woke up really early and wrote to
my editor and co-writer, Veronica.
And I mean, we had to narrow it down to three
hundred something pages, from like fifteen
hundred pages--something like that.
But, there's a lot of stories, a lot of moments
obviously that didn’t' get in there, but
you
know this book, like anything, was bad for
a long time before it got good.
So there was a lot of stuff out there and
how does this stuff--you
know--that's where Andy came in and really
edited this well.
And, how do I tell these stories?
I felt it like it was really about being
honest and not protecting--I knew when I walked
in I didn't want to do a victory lap.
It's so male and so tired.
[interviewer chuckles]
And I knew also that I wanted --if I'm going
to borrow time from the reader--borrow that
time--there's a lot of stuff they can
do--they needed to get to know me better.
Like I've read books about known people that
you know less about them after spent, like
for me, two weeks, 'cause I read slow and
I'm pissed after that.
[laughter]
You have to get to know me better than before,
right?
And also, learn something about yourself.
I want this book to be a sense of a
mirror to yourself like "You know what, what
are we doing in that space?
Are we hiring from this community?"
Well there's a
project right across the street here, how
many of those people work for Google?
Like questions, questions, questions.
What can we
do about that?
How can we engage in that community?
What responsibility do we have when we buy
these buildings?
Who that great for?
It's great for a lot of people, could be greater
for even more.
What can we do to engage?
Questions.
>>Interviewer: You know you're absolutely
right.
You raised some good questions.
I'd--
>>Marcus: Mmm hmm.
That's why we should hang out and have a beer
together.[Marcus laughs]
>>Interviewer: Let's hang out anytime you
want.
I'm on it.
>>Marcus: Yeah.
yeah.
>>Interviewer: I'll see you tomorrow.
[laughter] One of the things that you talk
about in the book is the failure of Merkato
which I actually had the pleasure of dining
at before it opened; that makes me sound like
an insider--it was for an event that you
were doing and I had the honor of dining at
your restaurant before it closed and you kind
of highlighted that as one of your
biggest professional disappointments.
It was quickly followed by, well in the book
it was quickly followed by Top Chef Masters,
cooking for the White House state dinner.
I'm curious what that failure taught you,
what the failure of Merkato 55 brought
out of you?
>>Marcus: It taught me a lot, I mean, there's
no way Rooster would have been as delicious
and yummy without that failure, right?
>>Interviewer: Why do you say that?
>>Marcus: Well, because you learn so much.
You guys learn so much.
You guys launch products all the time--
>>Interviewer: That fail.
>>Marcus: That fails miserably and these are
the smartest and the brightest, but I know
that you guys are sitting in war rooms and
saying "Why did it fail?
It can't fail.
We gotta do better," and you come back at
it right?
And-- so I think for me I learned about
the conversation about African fine dining
is not wrong.
That is not wrong.
I should have learned more about the community.
When
you're in the meat packing, there's nobody
would walk there on a Thursday at nine-thirty
that wants to have a Kumbaya African
experience.
They want to stand on a table, do shots, and
have a good ass time.
Well let them have it, but it should not be
African
good food, shouldn't be dragged down to that
misery.
And shame on me for thinking that they were
even on the same conversation.
I
think that is great that all that stuff is
there, and it has that incredible bridge and
tunnel feel,
[laughter]
which a bridge and tunnel should have, and
that has nothing to do with .
I should have kept the two out of the way.
So that's the quick answer right?
What else did it teach about myself?
You know it was 2006 when we signed the lease
and when
you're in this bubble of bigger, better, bigger,
better, you know that lease was, that rent
was about a hundred thousand dollars a month
for a
restaurant,
>>Interviewer: Wow.
>>Marcus: And we--I so wanted the deal I was
like "no problem, we'll just pack it."
You know and then you become chasing rent,
so
that informed my decision about doing something
that I would not be chasing--commit is still
to chase flavor, not to chasing rent.
It taught me so many things.
Again, the purity of the product wasn't wrong,
it was my head wasn't clear and I wanted to
do it too
bad so two things was good about it: we quit
before it got bad bad, and I learned on how
to listen and walk a neighborhood more.
And
that's why I walked around Harlem before I
engaged.
So hindsight, it all worked out, but it took
me a lot of self--sort of learning and so
it's like okay.
And it's good, it's good.
You get humbled and you listen and you get
better, or you don't and then there's another
path.
>>Interviewer: Well, in the book you bring
a lot of tastes so much to life, I'm wondering
if there's a cookbook in the works
for "Yes, Chef" like a journey of Chef Samuelsson?
>>Marcus: Yeah, I mean, a lot of people have
asked and actually---maybe it's called "No,
Chef" I don't know.
[Marcus and audience laugh]
I don't know.
We thought--I struggle with this a lot--but
I've never done anything where there wasn't
food.
I'm like, I know this is a
memoir but how many recipes can we--are we
going to have?
And Andy's like, "None."
My editor said, "None."
I was like, "Whoa!"
I
was nervous about how to engage with an audience
without food, and not stand on it in anyway.
Even when I speak, I always bring up
food terms.
So that was a first for me, and I think--I
don't even think about what's next in terms
of writing things in terms of
"Yes, Chef" right now, because I feel like
we're in the middle of it.
It's been a great run, and we have now, it's
sort of the
product of what comes out of it, I don't know.
We'll see.
>>Interviewer: Okay.
>>Marcus: But it's a interesting idea, yes--chef.
>>Interviewer: All right, we'll take a percentage.
So there was a great article just over the
weekend in The Times--
>>Marcus: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: --leading up to this event
I'm sure about [Marcus laughs] building--
>>Marcus: I love that!
>>Interviewer: About building your brand and
sort of the empire that is Marcus Samuelsson.
Can you talk to us a little bit about
the brand of Marcus Samuelsson and the pressure
of that and sort of how that's all going and
what's--
>>Marcus: Well I don't think any of it--I
get annoyed when you're a known person with
a platform and you talk about the pressure.
Pressure is being outside looking in.
Pressure is "How am I going to pay my rent?"
That's pressure.
"How am I going to provide for
my family?"
Anyone with a platform and has an option on
what to do and how to curate a grade--lucky.
You're lucky.
And you're privileged and
that's what my sort of obsession with curation
for the audience is, right?
Because I know if we don't take care of that,
lights
out.
Very quickly.
So I wouldn't--I never look at it as pressure.
I look at it as we have to be gooder than
the rest, there has to
be narrative because the people that take
time out and spend money with us deserve it.
And I think about everything that we touch
on that level.
And it has to be--it can never be a false
promise.
And if we're a two dollar cornbread, it should
feel like a
twenty-eight dollar cornbread.
And the reality is--
>>Interviewer: There's twenty-eight dollar
cornbread?
>>Marcus: Well--
>>Interviewer: Where are you eating?
Where--
>>Marcus: Truffles, truffles.
>>Interviewer: [laughs] Fair enough.
>>Marcus: The reality is that I live in a
community where most of those great, grand
experiences and amenities are south of that
community.
And I resent that.
And I'm not going to walk around angry, walking
around--"This is wrong, this is wrong."
That's not
gonna happen.
I'm going to provide it in my community first.
So when you do that trip, when you come with
that beautiful bag, that
changes your narrative of uptown and commercialism
is very fast.
It's now changed real estate, it's now changed
job progression, so
it'll happen and it can be cornbread at a
time.
If it's curated; if it's done really sticky,
yummy delicious.
>>Interviewer: And not twenty-eight dollars--
>>Marcus: And that's what I think about.
You think about the brand, well that's the
brand, right?
It's aspirational; it's inclusive
versus exclusive; and of course it's easier
when you're a Swedopian living in Harlem to
think about those because I have
different--I think about my grandmother from
Sweden or my sisters and brothers in Africa,
they're in my conversation.
And I think
about the chef that I grew up with, you know,
because it's an encompassing inclusiveness
that others might or might not have been
exposed to.
>>Interviewer: I want to open it up for questions
in a couple of minutes because there's a lot
of--
>>Marcus: No you don't.
You’re a good interviewer.
This is all you.
>>Interviewer: Thank you!
An Indian Oprah up here.
I just want to do a couple "finish this sentence
for me" and then we'll open it
up for questions.
>>Marcus: Oh wow.
>>Interviewer: So people can get ready to
ask their questions at one of the two mics
because we are recording for YouTube that
would be great.
So if you'll fin--are you ready?
>>Marcus: I'm ready.
>>Interviewer: All right.
Swedish food is?
>>Marcus: Salty, pickled, delicious.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: Fusion cooking is?
>>Marcus: Can be confusion-confusing, but
is also eye opener because it's cross right,
it's essentially a cross.
I think there's a
new word--I think we're going to look at Fusion
the way that we look at a fax machine or a
VCR.
It was a moment but there's
definitely a better product coming out of
that.
So--
>>Interviewer: What's a better word for it?
>>Marcus: You know, I don't know if I have
a good word for it, but I do think that it's
sort of like, it encompasses ethnic
somewhere right?
And cross?
Fusion, it comes from using in jazz, and sometimes
a food word gotta come and be in and of the
foods, you
know?
That's why when you work with foods like food
desert, it doesn't work because there's not
a desert in those places.
Like
it's got to come in and of--that's why I like--not
like but focus more on food chasm because
it's choices that we deliberately made
that certain people should be in on food and
good options and certain people should not.
It's not a desert, it's a decision.
>>Interview: Okay.
Junk food is?
>>Marcus: When I was a kid, it was aspirational,
because I never got it.
[laughter]
Never.
So it's like this thing over here, right,
but still, as bad as it is, it also inspires
us a lot to do--like when a chef
when we are fun we think about something we
use words as we go there we think about fast
cash, we think about burger but we do our
inspiration of it, we think about fries, but
we do our version, so it can be fast, it can
be delicious, depends on who makes it,
right?
It's like the author, it's like the chef.
So.
I suck at this thing by the way.
>>Interviewer: No, you're great at it.
[laughter] Good.
Food bloggers are?
>>Marcus: Hmm.
Well, we are--we now--we hire and we work
with The Tribe.
So, it took me a long time to understand that
whole thing.
A long time.
I like it now.
Took me a long time.
We joined.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: My favorite thing about Harlem
is?
>>Marcus: Oh, the people.
The people.
It's the closest thing to Africa, it's the
best thing of life.
Like I always say, it's like a
Polaroid picture.
Sh-sh-sh, oh there it is.
It's very--it's imperfect, it's perfect, it's
great.
Good.
>>Interviewer: Very Good.
>>Marcus: Good part of town.
>>Interviewer: Reality--
>>Marcus: Maybe we should have an office.
>>Interviewer: What's that?
>>Marcus: Where Google should have an office.
>>Interviewer: All right, I'll tell them.
>>Marcus: I'm a complete believer that tech
should be uptown.
Young people, lot of space, open minded, and
it would completely
change north Manhattan.
>>Interviewer: There's a lot of movement towards
sort of a tech center/entrepreneurial center
in the Bronx.[mumbles]
>>Marcus: Mmm Hmm.
Great.
>>Interviewer: Reality chef competitions are?
>>Marcus: Fun, exhausting, and I love the
fact that it gets the family involved.
So many times when you have like kids and
parents
coming like "we--" --I'll tell you a funny
thing like I did a cooking class in the Harlem
and this kid come up to me and I was
doing the salad between the chicken and some
cheese, he said, "Chef, is that ricotta?"
and he was thirteen years old, and I was
like, "Yeah, how do you know that?"
He's like, "I'm watching Chop, you know?"
[laughter] And the window in, the fact that
"Whoa" I
had not idea the difference between Ricotta
or Brie at thirteen years old.
So it can be that and if it is the window
into for us to eat better or
learn, have conversation about food--fantastic!
It can also be very similar to sports right?
We watch more sports, doesn't mean
that we are healthier.
[laughter] So it really depends--it really
depends how you do it.
>>Interviewer: I think many American men watching
football on Saturday, or Sunday rather, would
disagree with that.
They think
they're very healthy.
My husband being one of them, just watching
the football.
>>Marcus: Yeah, yeah.
>>Interviewer: I told him he's not actually
on the team, but he doesn't agree with me
at all.
>>Marcus: Yeah, in his mind at that moment,
he is.
>>Interviewer: Yeah, he's on the team.
He's the coach.
>>Marcus: Yeah.
>>Interviewer: Home is?
>>Marcus: Harlem, uptown.
>>Interviewer: Awesome.
Thank you.
>>Marcus: Good.
All right.
>>Interviewer: Any questions?
>>Marcus: Yeah, we have to have questions.
>>Interviewer: We have somebody waiting up
there?
>>Marcus: I like it.
>>Male speaker #1: Before I get to my question,
may I add one thing to your "Do not ever say
again" list?
Tech is for young.
>>Marcus: You're right.
You're right.
>>Interviewer: That's true.
>>Marcus: That's is--you're right.
Shame on me.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: You're being schooled.
>>Marcus: I can't wait for the game though.
>>Male speaker #1: Another learning.
>>Marcus: Yeah.
>>Male speaker #1: I have a nephew whose been
enthusiastic about food since he was four,
I mean we gave him espresso cups as a
birthday present when he was four, and he
was already working on his knife skill thing--
>>Interviewer: What could possibly go wrong?
[laughter]
>>Male speaker #1: He's just finishing up
his first year at Johnson and Wales in Providence--
>>Marcus: Nice, good school.
Good choice.
>>Male speaker #1: But after a summer of doing
nothing but making Pico de Gallo, he's really
thinking seriously now about "Maybe I want
to be a food scientist working for a big corporation,
maybe this restaurant thing is not for me,"
I mean might he be on the right
track or might he be missing something.
I mean it's an incredibly tough lifestyle,
it's incredibly tough life.
Is he blowing it
off too soon or maybe being wise that it's
not for everybody?
>>Marcus: Well, I think the good thing with
him is he's asking himself important questions.
And, you know, where he is in that
stage of "Who am I?" and "What do I want?"
right?
Today, in cooking, you can be an incredible
food scientist and Johnson and Wales
was a good part of that journey.
When I was coming up, you could basically
chef.
That was one area--to be chef, so there's
twenty
entry levels today about cooking, I think
him finding this out, he's on his own path
and journey, is the answer and the great thing
is that he can do that, and then when he's
twenty-five, twenty-six, maybe he wants to
try a restaurant again, and then maybe he
wants to solve how to make the best deep fried
chicken the healthiest in the world and guess,
he sits on the knowledge on both
sides then by then.
The path that he's on, I think, is more of
what the common new chef is going to be like.
It's not just one area
of the guy who didn't like to go to school,
became a chef.
That was what my generation pretty much came
out of.
The next one's
going to come in so many different levels
and he represents that.
So, his journey's his journey.
I would never put tough or
challenging around being a chef.
I just don't think that's --. When you truly
--it's your craft--it picked you and
you picked--it's tougher to do something you
don't like.
Because you'd rather work fifteen hours a
day with something that you
love, than twelve hours a day with something
that you hate, right?
That's really the math that you have to do.
So, that's that.
>>Male Speaker #1: Thank you very much.
>>Marcus: Thank you.
Yes?
>>Female speaker #1: Hi, so--
>>Marcus: Take that mic down a little bit,
come on.
[laughter]
>>Female speaker #1: It was for a taller person.
>>Marcus: Yes.
>>Female speaker #1: So going back to the
book, I read it, I thought it was so moving,
it's clearly such a distinctly you
story, but when it resonates with so many
people.
I was so curious what it was like to work
with a writer on such a personal story,
what she brought to the party and--
>>Marcus: Yeah.
Yeah, a lot.
>>Female speaker #1: How the process changed
because of it?
>>Marcus: Well, she brought spelling.
[laughter]
How about that basic, you know after I've
lived in six countries, and I can't spell
in one language well.
I can't.
I mean, I keep
this sort of twelve year old sort of knowledge--actually
younger, nine year old sort of vocabulary
because I don't know how to
spell those words I want to say so--she brought
that, but I also had to be--you know I knew
Veronica, I knew Veronica for a long
time--and the trust was everything right?
So Veronica--very thoughtful, and she knew
the story I needed and wanted and was
committed to tell.
And I'm so privileged that Random House, and
it was three years in a row I'd have to go
Random House and say
"Hey, the book's not good, we got to wait
a year."
Three years.
And they supported it.
And I was nervous taking that elevator up
because so many times they could have just
said "You know what, we're going to cancel
the whole thing."
But they supported it because
they wanted--there was a good story in there.
And I was very grateful for that and Veronica
and Andy, the editor, constantly kept
me, "It's got to be stories, it's got to be
good stories."
When if it wasn't good, we eighty-sixed it.
We didn't put it.
So working
with her specifically was about trust, and
she spends way too much time with me for her
family.
You know she came up and not with a
[unintelligible],
[Interviewer coughs]
I mean she made it work.
She brought her daughter in the kitchen and
her husband came and I always had to constantly
pay them
with fried chicken.
[laughter] But you know, we were committed,
we were in a band, you know.
So much about doing this when you give
is you got to be in, in, and if you're not,
then you can't tell a story.
So.
[Interviewer coughs]
>>Interviewer: Excuse me.
Any other questions?
>> Marcus: Well, great.
[laughter]
>>Interviewer: I asked them all.
>>Marcus: Yes.
>>Interviewer: Thank you so much--
>>Marcus: Thank you.
It's always a privilege to get here.